now of all the medical conditions
gout seems to be
a very mysterious condition
you know the theory of um
we're consuming too many purine
type foods
and the uric acid that is broken down
from purines is
developing crystals
that deposit in your big toe
yet so many people that go on a low
purine diet
don't seem to get rid of their gout
and then people that get on medications
just don't like the side effects
that these medications create so today
i'm going to show you a very effective
remedy
for gout using
a different strategy but first i wanted
to mention some very interesting things
about god that you should know about
most of the uric acid that is in your
body
the great majority of it
is coming from an endogenous source
whereas an endogenous mean it means that
your body's creating it okay your body
is making this uric acid
only a small amount of uric acid comes
externally from your diet and 50 of the
people that experience gout attacks have
normal uric acid and the crystals that
are forming from these uric acid
crystals
are not even in the exact location where
someone is experiencing or feeling the
gout attack and of course the other
point is about genetics you know if they
can't figure out what what's causing it
it's probably just your genes
but that also has some holes there is a
genetic tendency for gout
but mainly in australia i think one out
of 20 people in australia get gout due
to their genes but out of all the people
that have a genetic propensity to have
gout
only 10 of those people
actually have gout attacks so there's
just so much confusion in this area it's
ridiculous and so apparently in a gout
attack
um the pain is not necessarily coming
from the crystals that are digging into
your tissues
it's coming from an immune reaction okay
there's some immune response
that's getting triggered from the uric
acid crystals
that's what's causing the inflammation
so how do we do with gut attacks well i
have found that when people go off
carbohydrates sugars especially fructose
high fructose corn syrup
alcohol especially beer
just that change alone
handles a lot of problems with gout but
there are still people that do that and
they still have gut attacks
so what can be done
well we do know this one fact about gout
in order for uric acid crystals to form
okay
so your immune system can react to it
your ph
has to be
more on the acidic side we know that so
based on that data
if you were to alkalize the body just a
little bit and i'm talking about urine
alkalization therapy
that can give you some immediate relief
so if we combine that
with the ketogenic diet which is low
carb as well as intermittent fasting i
think
you'll be in really good shape so what
is the best remedy to alkalize the urine
sodium bicarbonate would be the primary
thing that would give you the least
amount of side effects
and i'm talking about baking soda now
before i tell you how to take it some
people are sodium sensitive
they're on a certain low sodium diet
because of high blood pressure whatever
if that's your situation
i would recommend using potassium
citrate instead however baking soda will
work a little bit better and of course
baking soda and water doesn't always
taste that good so
if i were going to take it i would
recommend adding some potassium citrate
now if you wanted a really good
potassium citrate of course i'm going to
recommend my own electrolyte powder
because it's slightly sweetened and has
a good amount of potassium citrate
so you would add one scoop of that
with the baking soda but you don't have
to do that you can just use baking soda
alone now as far as the amount of baking
soda i would recommend starting out with
a smaller amount like 1 8 of a teaspoon
in a glass of water about 8 ounces okay
and i would do that for a couple days
and then i would increase that to a
fourth of a teaspoon of baking soda then
i would increase that to a half a
teaspoon of baking soda and depending on
the severity of this gout attack you may
want to try this once twice or
three times a day
on an empty stomach spaced out about an
hour okay so you would take it wait an
hour take another dose wait another hour
take another dose that should pretty
much put your gout attack in remission
now you don't want to take this with
meals because it's alkalizing and it can
dilute your hydrochloric acid so taking
an empty stomach at least an hour before
you eat
this is also a good remedy if you have
uric acid kidney stones okay
that's a little bit different than the
oxalate stones but with other types of
stones you'll be better off acidifying
the urine
so there's always this question of
how far you go before you've gone too
far because you don't want to go too far
on the alkaline side and you don't want
to go too far on the acidic side so i'm
going to put a link down below
for information to determine if you're
too alkaline okay and then you would
back off if that was the case
now another bit of research i want to
touch on
is using transdermal
sodium bicarbonate so apparently um
there was a study done that took sodium
bicarbonate and put it into a patch okay
where you can put it topically where it
can absorb right into the big toe
and this would avoid
taking it internally
due to the high amounts of sodium yet i
couldn't seem to find a source where you
can find this transdermal
baking soda so i have nothing to put in
the link on that however
this may work i don't know you'd have to
test it
but to dissolve baking soda in some
water and then soaking your toe in it
and there's also some interesting
research that baking soda can increase
your immune system primarily your
macrophages which actually can help
reduce inflammation
as well as baking soda increasing your t
cell so apparently it does affect the
immune system as well and that's really
what gout is it's an immune problem this
is why a lot of people use it for
autoimmune conditions because it can
tone down the inflammation now the other
thing you need to know about gout is
that there's a very very high incidence
of gout
in people with metabolic syndrome this
means that they're consuming too many
carbs
so usually when someone's doing the you
know the organ meats or the red meats
and things like that
they're usually at the same time
consuming beer or carbohydrates so i
really do not believe it's the meats
that are causing this gout attack at all
in fact a lot of people when they go
carnivore
get rid of their gout but for those
people on the ketogenic diet
from interviewing a lot of people that
are trying to get rid of their gown
they're doing a great job but usually
they're adding in
a little bit of the wrong carbohydrates
they're usually not doing the ketogenic
diet
standardly like i recommend it they're
sort of doing a ketogenic diet so when
they get on a very strict ketogenic diet
they tend to do much much better but
there's some key things that you need to
avoid if you have gout okay number one
of course the obvious sugar in all forms
of sugar which also includes
maltodextrin which i just did a video on
the second thing is all the refined
grains and refined carbohydrates okay
and then also when we're talking about
sugars
there's one sugar alcohol that can
increase the risk of getting out and
that would be xylitol so if you do have
gout you'd be better off using another
type of sugar alcohol like
erythritol something like that but just
realize if you're using stevia or monk
fruit many times
they add in maltodextrin which is a very
bad corn sugar that i would recommend
avoiding especially if you have gout now
of course alcohol and especially beer
can increase your risk of getting out
and even medications like aspirin
like diuretics
can increase the risk of gout the worst
sugar for gout would be fructose
and even certain vitamins like niacin
can trigger gout attacks so niacin is
really good for
helping someone with cholesterol
problems i mean it's it's been totally
scientifically proven to do that but if
you have gout
taking another form of b3 would be much
better and that would be niacinamide
okay that's the
version of niacin that doesn't give you
the flush
so
niacinamide will help you with gout and
arthritis
but not necessarily cholesterol but if
you don't have gut attacks you'd be
better off taking niacin now that you
have that information i want to share a
related video that i think you'll find
very interesting
on sodium i put it right here check it
out
you